the government the global Elite whatever
you want to call them they want men to
be weak fat and compliant because it's
their men that go to war it's the men
that fight and when you're busy watching
porn all day playing video games all day
eating bugs you don't have the power in
you to go and fight the Tyranny you're
just soft and pathetic sitting on a
couch and you can be controlled and
that's exactly what they want and women
unfortunately and I'm happy to say this
is a woman we don't really know any
better we're not emotionally or
physically resilient enough to go and
fight the Tyranny men are the ones that
can do that we should be the ones
raising the Next Generation nurturing
the children while the men go out and
protect and provide when the men are
weak fat and compliant well then